[Girl shown with big smile.]
[Girl is sitting at table with plates of food and a glass of milk.]
[Girl cuts up food and eats.]
[Diagram of a tooth with a pointer showing where the enamel is located.]
[Diagram of a tooth with a pointer showing where the Cementum is located.]
[Diagram of a tooth with a pointer showing where the Dentine is located.]
[Diagram of a tooth with a pointer showing where the Dental Pulp is located.]
[Girl is shown sitting at table eating and drinking.]
[Girl is sitting at a table with a plate of fruit. ]
[She chooses an apple and bites into it. Close-up of the girl chewing.]
[Close-up of a mouth with lips pulled back. Teeth are stained and unclean.]
[The mouth opens and closes.]
[A hygienist is shown welcoming a young boy to a dental chair.]
[The boy sits down and the hygienist puts a dental bib on him.]
[The hygienist pulls a tray of dental tools towards her.]
[The hygienist looks at the boy's teeth with a dental mirror.]
[The hygienist scrapes the boy's upper front teeth.]
[The hygienist paints the teeth with a dark solution.]
[Close-up of the boy's mouth as solution is being applied.]
[The hygienist scrapes the teeth again.]
[Close-up of boy's mouth while the hygienist scrapes his teeth.]
[The hygienist polishes a front tooth.]
[She uses a mirror to view the boy's back teeth.]
[Close-up of the boy's mouth as a dark solution is painted on his back teeth.]
[Close-up of the hygienist scraping the teeth with a dental tool.]
[Using a handheld model, the hygienist gives the boy a demonstration of the correct way to brush one's teeth.]
[Close-up of the hygienist showing the correct way to brush teeth using herself as a model.]
[Diagram of teeth with a pointer indicating the starting points of decay.]
[Pointer shows areas where decay can start.]
[Points to surface of molars, then to areas between teeth where they touch.]
[Diagram of one tooth.]
[Pointer again points to flat part of molar.]
[Animation shows cavity developing and spreading through the enamel.]
[Animation shows cavity spreading through dental pulp.]
[A male dentist is shown in an office with a young girl sitting in a dental chair.]
[The dentist wipes his hands and picks up a dental instrument.]
[The dentist is working in the patient's mouth with tools.]
[Close-up of the girl's mouth as the dentist examines her teeth.]
[Close-up of the dentist drilling out a cavity.]
[A solution is sprayed on the tooth.]
[A piece of gauze is used to clean out the cavity area.]
[The dentist fills the tooth with another substance.]
[A diagram of teeth in an early stage of decay is shown.]
[A pointer indicates the decayed areas.]
[A pointer shows the second and third stages of decay.]
[A pointer indicates a large cavity, the 4th stage of decay.]
[Close-up of a mouth with a dental mirror showing a cavity.]
[An animated diagram shows a tooth as the cavity gets bigger and bigger.]
[Animation shows the spread of decay throughout the tooth, followed by formation of an abscess.]
[Two young girls are looking at a magazine.]
[One girl sucks on her finger.]
[Close-up of a mouth with a mirror showing how the upper teeth are protruding.]
[Close-up of mouth with poorly developed teeth.]
[Close-up of mouth with spaces between front teeth on top and on bottom.]
[Close-up of crooked and misaligned teeth.]
[Close up of mouth with braces on the teeth.]
[Close-up of mouth with straight teeth.]
[A girl is shown in a bathroom preparing to brush her teeth.]
[The girl brushes her teeth and tongue.]
[The girl flosses her teeth.]